be be closer don't have it out there
like that so here your tight tight on
your body start to check the height
use the thumb fulcrum right rip it
bruised lose your balance so nice and
tight tight tight
my forearm is almost going towards the
gun right crank it down switch through
balance
[Music]
you don't get enough balance right come
back the other way so same thing nice
and tight tight tight tight down right
and then you'll do the same grip when
you when you do just learn remember turn
it inside don't move his wrist like this
turn it inside his grip boom turn inside
your script crank this whip try to get
it all the motions on throw and bully
rip it out as he still falling in that
direction so boom pop you ripping it out
[Music]
not down at the bottom they'll roll with
you let me go this way so turn the
clitoris and he's falling oh wait is
working against you so keep it moving
keep it moving try to regain control
keep them moving
[Music]
flavor